what lessons do you draw
from those other famines if you've
looked at them
or in general about famine that are
manufactured by the decisions of let's
say authoritarian leaders
um
famine doesn't have to exist or the bulk
of fandoms famines on this planet i
believe don't have to exist and most of
them
uh or at least a good number of them are
manufactured by the leaders um
that choose to use
famine as a weapon right and and
ukraine is the
one of the obvious examples right now
you know with siege tactics that are
happening in different parts of the
country
and um
you know
we built international humanitarian law
for a reason right many years ago
and it continues to be written to this
day
and it's there
to prevent what's happening in ukraine
right now it's there to prevent what's
been happening in yemen for seven years
and yet there hasn't been any teeth
behind it
and that's what disturbs me
is that
we can see
how these famines are being used as
weapons in war
and yet
we aren't sort of using the levers of
power that exist
in order to
i think to call out
in important and powerful ways those who
are causing them and to make sure that
we hold them accountable on the global
stage now to some extent that seems to
be happening
in ukraine in a way that hasn't happened
for a long time and that that gives me
hope right and yet i don't believe we've
done enough
um and i think the the national
community needs to do far more than we
are both in yemen in ethiopia um and in
ukraine right now
there are certain kinds of things that
captivate
the global attention
and it seems like starvation is not
always one of them
for some reason murder
and destruction
gets people attention more
it's the death of course is easy to
enumerate but it's the suffering that's
the problem yeah
yeah you know when we went to film
hunger ward that was one of the creative
questions that i was really concerned
about because starvation
you know it's not a quick action
right it's a long
slow insidious process right just like
hunger
right and yet
when you're hungry right
um it takes you over
it becomes the most important thing
right it's just absolutely fundamental
to to life it's like drying breath
and so i i really
before i filmed hunger ward i i
struggled to sort of answer
how we could creatively approach that
because you know
someone sitting in a clinic right
starving or being treated for starvation
you know that's a pretty static scene
right
um
and what we found was that because of
the volume of cases and because of the
nature of sort of
how quickly
um
people were coming and going is that it
was more dynamic than we anticipated
and there's something also about
starvation
you get tired
it's almost like uh it's a quiet
suffering
yeah
like uh
and by the way there's something about
when i think about dark times i mean you
you you'll hear me chuckle for example i
don't know what that is
that's almost like
it's almost like you you have to kind of
laugh at
uh you can't help but laugh at like
uh the injustice and the cruelty in the
world somehow that helps your mind deal
with it i mean i see this all the time
like when you're struggling you can't
feed your family you lost your home
the last thing you have
is jokes about humor yes humans
it's like
the [ __ ] man [ __ ] me over again
and there's jokes all around that yeah
and and then and then you laugh and you
drink vodka and you play music i don't
know what that is i don't know what that
is it's gallows humor right it's it's
it's a way of
a way of i think simultaneously
acknowledging and allowing yourself to
move forward right beyond the pain and
the suffering
you